[Music]
[Applause]
it's bringing Rick newheisel he covers
college football part of cbs's Studio
crew for the SEC title game between
Georgia and LSU also in studio for Army
Navy that's next Saturday December 10th
on CBS and Rick newhives or good buddy
joins us on the program well
tell me did the committee get it right
I think they got the right four teams
Dan I just don't think they got the
right order uh for Georgia to finish
number one
and to have to play Ohio State
I guarantee you they would not have
chosen that as their opponent uh in the
semi-final
also it's a TV show that's but I always
wonder Ohio State Michigan and you had
that in the final four look TCU may be a
sacrificial lamb but that's okay you
would have a monster game with Ohio
State in Michigan and and maybe I'm
being a little too Starkey with this but
it is a TV show that they're producing
Rick
absolutely and to say as boo Corrigan
said uh Therese Davis that that never
came up that it would be an Ohio State
Michigan rematch that that no one
acknowledged the elephant in the room
that must be a very small room if no one
said it in the room because it was said
elsewhere I guarantee
if TCU had lost by double digits
finish that sentence Alabama probably
nudges in but as you look at Alabama's
resume as good as we as we know them to
be you have to sit there and acknowledge
that their best win was probably whether
it's the Mississippi State win or the
Texas win and neither one of those the
Mississippi State one was a dominant win
the the Texas win was you know Bryce
young doing heroic things again
Alabama's outside looking in because
Alabama didn't play up to their
potential it's Alabama's fault
why not have Tennessee ranked ahead of
Alabama since they beat Alabama
it's a glitch it's a glitch I understand
that uh Tennessee looked horrible in the
uh game against South Carolina and maybe
you add in that hen and hookers no
longer available uh but it's a glitch
when you're right next to one another
same record and one beat the other uh
that shouldn't have gone to print they
should have had Tennessee back ahead of
them
do we have a Heisman winner is Caleb
Williams and then I think so you know at
the end I didn't see the much of the
first half of the game I was at a dinner
and unfortunately wasn't able to watch
when he got hurt uh I felt like at the
end of the game he was you know
obviously depressed over what was taking
place but watching the film of the game
Dan they took the Utah uh defense
realized he was wounded and the entire
offense went away the the all the Run
fits they didn't have to worry about him
keeping the ball it was uh it was
pouncing on a wounded animal and and uh
it was ugly to watch but Caleb Williams
was fantastic from start to finish we're
talking to the former college coach Rick
newheisel who was at UCLA in Washington
and Colorado and Colorado and Colorado
and now Dion comes in
your reaction
well I'm happy for Dion uh you know I
was with him uh my little brief tenure
in the NFL the Ravens that was his last
stop along his NFL career so I got to be
around Dion and love him and I doubt not
in the least that he's going to be uh
uh successful because he's got such a
magnetism to him and he'll be caught up
in the recruiting World very quickly
what I didn't like is that on one side
he's telling the kids at Jackson State
be careful before you put yourself in
the portal because you might not find a
home and then he arrives in Colorado and
tells everybody to go in the portal you
know you I brought my own luggage you
know I'm gonna I got guys that are
playing these roles these are kids and
somewhere somehow Dan and I don't know
who's going to take responsibility but
we've got 40 percent of these kids
getting it put in this portal whether
it's their active pressing send in the
computer or somebody nudging him as we
saw Dion look like that was a giant
nudge to the Colorado roster
who where who's going to be on the hook
for their uh education because that's
what this was supposed to be about and I
think it's a bigger issue and I think
the the the the adults in the room have
to sit down and figure that out okay so
he I was surprised that he went to
Colorado it felt like that he had built
up a good enough resume that there would
be other opportunities there I know his
alma mater turned their backs on him a
couple of years ago but why Colorado
well in this cycle uh there wasn't
another opportunity there would have
been there's no question to cachet that
he was developing as a college football
coach was growing and there would have
been an opportunity but I think he just
said you know I'm going to start on this
Quest
moving forward and I I wouldn't be
surprised that if he moves from Colorado
to a to a uh more prominent position in
the college football World assuming that
Colorado doesn't become that I mean it
wasn't so long ago that Colorado was a
top 10 team
yeah I understand that you're as low as
you could possibly be but you're also
you know now these these schools and
chancellors and presidents athletic
directors have to look at it and go
there's going to be 12 opportunities
here to make the playoffs and you can
turn a football program around a whole
lot quicker than we used to
oh as we saw Brian Kelly and we saw
Lincoln Riley do literally overnight uh
they they both had programs that you
know had the resources with name image
and likeness and and uh the cachet to
get into the transfer portal and and
change their fortunes literally
overnight but uh and and I'm sure as
Rick George says I don't have the money
now the athletic director at Colorado
but I'll find it that part of that deal
is he's going to find some nil money to
uh lure people to the Rockies as well if
you're Jim Harbaugh I know that these
NFL rumors have come up again I don't
know what Jim is doing differently than
he did a couple years better or not he
better not you can't see a scenario
where you know he got him to the final
four and proved that he is a great coach
even though they had him take a pay cut
a couple of years ago that now he I mean
it feels like the NFL is still there for
him whether it should be or not
listen there's no question and how close
he wants to get to the flame uh is is
entirely up to him I think we all admire
the job that he's done he keeps talking
about uh a locker room of Heroes uh and
how much he's enjoying these these uh
relationships with the youngsters he
seems like a guy who's really happy uh
in his own skin but if this dalliance
and this idea of Super Bowl that his
brother has a Super Bowl trophy and he
doesn't uh keeps luring him to the flame
then then so be it but the way he talked
after getting you know a okay come back
inside son you know after the dalliance
with the Vikings toward manual I I don't
think you know as June said to Ward I
don't know that they're going to be nice
to the beaver again if he does it again
uh Nick Saban the politician did his
best but uh how angry is it more anger
disappointment do you think would say
even in Alabama
I think it's disappointment and I think
uh you know he doesn't waste many
opportunities to learn from mistakes the
leadership on that team I think is going
to be what's going to be examined uh was
there the kind of you know
uh what was the
the a personality type A personality on
that team to get that team to understand
that you have to play at the highest
level when you go into these because
you're always going to be on the hunted
list now Kirby Smart on the other side
says no we're the Hunter and what for
whatever reason they found themselves in
far too many close games given the
talent that they have on that ball Club
Great to talk to you as always thank you
Rick happy holidays Dan that's Rick new
Heisel part of the CBS Studio crew he'll
be in studio for Army Navy that'll be on
Saturday and that'll be on CBS